Of course there's the old saying,
I forget who said it,
but I think it's was turned my life,
which is if at the age of 21,
you,
you're not a socialist,
then you don't have any,
any heart.
And if by the age 30,
you still are and then you don't have
any brains.
So that was kind of my experience.
I started out young and idealistic and,
uh,
social justice and fair distribution of
resources.
And we were,
I didn't understand where everybody
couldn't be equally prosperous.
And starting my own business,
um,
was kind of a wake up call and a number
of different ways.
I had to,
I had to meet a payroll every week and
we had to satisfy customers and we had
competitors that we had to,
uh,
compete with in order to have those
customers come into our stores.
And we had to compete with other
employers for our,
uh,
for our employees.
We had to,
but the wages were under competitive
pressures.
So there was all this competition on us
that,
uh,
that of course made the operating the
business successfully difficult.
And it's kind of like having to meet a
payroll and having to meet the demands
of our customers is a great a destroyer
of Utopian fantasies and utopia and
utopia and ideologies.
You,
you're in the real world and you have
to,
you have to meet the market test every
day and every week.
And I just found that the belief system
that I had going into operating that
business was,
was inadequate to explain the
experiences that I was having in
business.
And I began to look around and read
other books and other philosophies to
try and make sense out of,
out of my life and out of my business
experience.
And it was really through encountering
the,
the free market capitalist philosophies
of,
uh,
of Milton Friedman and,
and,
uh,
Friedrich Hayak and Lou [inaudible] and
and,
and many other,
uh,
free market philosophers that I came to
realize that this explanation made a lot
more sense in my business experience and
made more sense in terms of how the
world really operated.
And so that's when my worldview began to
shift and I began to let go of being a
sort of a democratic socialist.
Any type of political ideology is going
to have a lot of different variants of
it,
a lot of different,
uh,
libertarians are,
are constantly arguing with each,
um,
who's the most pure libertarian and
who's most Aila,
ideologically pure.
Uh,
I have no real interest in those types
of discussions or arguments.
And,
uh,
I would,
I resist in one of the strains of
libertarianism and I reject,
I reject the idea that humankind is
essentially selfish.
That,
uh,
not only as an observation that we
frequently are selfish,
but there's a strain of belief,
uh,
particularly in the,
in the Ein Rand,
uh,
part of the movement that the leaves
people ought to be selfish.
That,
that that's a virtue that humans are
always self interested in.
And all truism is evil and love is,
uh,
is something that makes us weak.
And so I reject that aspect of allude to
libertarianism.
I'm,
um,
I'm a caring,
compassionate person and I believe that
free markets and free minds leads to the
greatest human flourishing.
So I really want humans to flourish and
I believe liberty and market economies
and capitalism and the best strategies
for full human flourishing.
So I don't identify with that strain of
libertarianism that,
uh,
is sort of uncaring and,
kind of,
uh,
Social Darwinian,
a variant of it.
Um,
I'm very uncomfortable without,
I,
I'm not that way myself.
I do believe that many libertarians are
animated by a human flourishing.
They,
they,
we sincerely believe that human
flourishing is that we need to be free
and that we need to be creative.
And that through human freedom,
entrepreneurship,
uh,
that humans are creative,
they create new ways of,
uh,
of creating value for each other that
expresses itself through the economic
system and leads to greater prosperity.
Not for a few,
but for,
for most people and eventually all
people.
So there is a strain of,
of,
of deep idealism in the libertarian
movement.
It's again,
sometimes masta over by that,
uh,
that ideology of selfishness.
But,
uh,
the human flourishing element is
definitely a big aspect of,
uh,
I think of the motivational structure of
many,
many libertarian.
Certainly it is for me,
I think the zero sum worldview is the
predominant one.
Uh,
I think it's,
it's something we've,
we've evolved with this idea that
there's a,
a limited fixed pie and we have to uh,
distribute that pie and equal fairway
that no one should get a unfair large
pieces of that pie.
And if someone is getting a bigger piece
necessarily,
someone else may be getting a smaller
piece since there's a finite amount of
pie to go around.
I also think it's comes from our,
our competitive sports and that in
competitive sports there's a,
there's a winner and there's a loser.
And so we play games,
we play sports all our lives.
So we come to believe that that in the
zero sum worldview,
that summer winters and some are losers
and in,
and then we can adjust society,
that there should be no losers,
there should be a,
and so we need to,
to,
to limit the,
the pieces of the pie anyone gets so
that everyone can have a fair and just
piece of the Pie.
And I,
so I reject that.
I don't think there is a,
uh,
necessarily a fixed pie.
The beauty of capitalism and the beauty
of conscious capitalism is the
realization that the pie can grow that,
that through voluntary exchange in
through the value creation that happens
when the stakeholders,
uh,
voluntarily cooperate and voluntary
exchange,
which with each other is that,
that the pie grows larger.
And so there is more to distribute and
that distribution takes place through
the market,
uh,
for the mark to market process is
through the exchange process as each,
as each of the traders of course wants
to get a bigger piece for themselves.
And competition sort of ultimately
determines the,
the percentages that each of the
different constituencies or stakeholders
gets in the exchanges.
But that's a growing pie and it's a win,
win,
win game.
And that turns me on.
I'm very fired up and excited about that
because it means human flourishing isn't
trapped in some type of,
uh,
limited,
set of constraints.
It means we can innovate and create our
ways out of the knee.
These traps in these,
uh,
sort of,
I can't remember or think of the phrase
right now.
I'm trying to,
I'm trying to recall,
but this idea that we're in some type
of,
of trap of limited resources and the
only limitations we have in the
limitations of human creativity,
human imagination and,
uh,
intellectual capital that's been
accumulated as we continue to gain an
intellectual,
uh,
capital and his human creativity is
unleashed and human entrepreneurship is
unleashed.
Then the new,
the new innovations,
the new creativity that expresses itself
through the marketplace,
through capitalism,
allows us to solve that.
Previously were thought to be insoluble,
uh,
and human and humans,
continue on the upward spiral.
I mean,
a great example of this is,
is,
uh,
people are very focused oftentimes on
the fact that there's still a billion
people on this planet that say live on
less than a dollar a day.
And that's,
uh,
and that's certainly is a terrible
tragedy.
But if you put that in historical
context,
that's about 15% of the people.
Uh,
15,
16,
17,
less than 20% of the people alive on the
planet live on less than a dollar a day.
Whereas 200 years ago,
85% of the people alive on the planet
earth lived on less than a dollar in
day.
And the US in today's dollars adjusted
for inflation.
So poverty has always been the default
condition of the human race.
What's unprecedented is not poverty.
What's unprecedented is wealth.
Wealth for not a few,
but prosperity for literally billions of
people every,
every year.
Now we see hundreds of millions of
people escape from poverty just in two
countries,
China and India.
It is the greatest revolution in human
prosperity in all of human history.
It's all occurred in the last 20 years.
And it's,
it's a,
it's a fact that you almost never see
reported in the media.
Instead,
we tend to focus still on there,
on the remaining people that are po,
uh,
that are,
are the rapport and we're back on our
zero sum gain at some higher nother.
That's because other people are greedy
and selfish and they're keeping these
poor people down rather than seeing
poverty lesson through capitalism and
through free market,
uh,
expansion,
we tend to condemn the very thing that's
allowing people to escape from poverty
as the cause of the poverty.
And it's ridiculous.
It's a,
the capitalism and free markets or
what's going to allow us to escape from
poverty.
Muhammad Yunus likes to say that,
that by the end of the 21st century,
poverty will be something that we only
see in museums that,
uh,
it'll be something people look back on
and say,
Gosh,
we used to have poor people.
How did,
uh,
how is that even possible?
And I do think that's the future of
humanity if we don't totally mess it up,
that we are going to continue to learn.
We're going to have our intellectual
capital spread.
We're going to unleash the human
creativity,
uh,
because I do believe humans have
limitless creativity and we're going to
solve a lot of these problems that are
holding us back now and humanity is
going to continue to its upward spiral.
And then we're gonna eliminate poverty.
I think there are people alive today.
Uh,
I perhaps will not live to see the end
of it,
but there are young people alive today
that we'll probably see the virtual end
of poverty in the human race in the 21st
century.
From a macro perspective,
conscious capitalism is becoming
conscious of the framework that
capitalism has to exist him in order to,
in order to be successful,
in order to flourish.
There certain key principles that that
have to be in place and we have to
nurture those principles or we won't
have a capitalistic order.
It's not something that automatically
exist and has to be.
It has to have principles as to be
grounded in those principles.
And some of those principles include,
um,
uh,
property rights that we have to have the
right for people to be able to own
property.
At the same time,
there needs to be the freedom to
exchange property.
We need to be able to trade it.
We need to be able to create something
and then trade it or sell it to someone
else.
We need,
we need a rule of law.
There needs to be laws that are just,
and laws that are predictable and laws
that apply to everyone in the society,
including the government.
And the rule of law is essential.
You cannot have a,
a capitalistic order without the rule of
law.
And it,
whenever that comes into doubt or if
they're not stable property rights,
you don't really have the,
the basis for the capitalistic order.
And finally you need a,
uh,
freedom to trade,
usually the greater the,
uh,
the fewer restrictions on their freedom
to trade across the,
uh,
between people,
but also between people in different
states,
people in different countries,
the,
the greater value creation that occurs.
So anytime you see a society that's
beginning to um,
restrict the ability to trade,
you see a society that is going to
lessen its prosperity.
It a and P it tends to happen when
people get preoccupied with the loss of
jobs.
Not Understanding that you may lose some
jobs to a foreign country if you allow
freedom to trade,
but you gaining jobs at the same time,
your gain more net jobs because the
people won't give you their goods for
free.
They want to trade with you as well.
And so those jobs and the goods that
they want to trade for the good and
services they want,
that will create greater employment,
uh,
at home.
But that's very hard for the average
person to understand.
And so,
um,
but anyway,
conscious capitalism is understanding
these,
these basic core economic values and
becoming more conscious of them.
Now conscious,
uh,
business is,
is there are certain principles behind
that.
And one principle is that business has
the potential for higher purpose that
uh,
maximizing profits.
If you ask people what the purpose of
businesses,
they usually say,
if you go to a cocktail party and asked
that question,
they'll generally say,
well,
everybody knows that the purpose of of
businesses to maximize profits,
it's to maximize shareholder value.
And it's,
but that's a very odd answer because
that's not the answer we would give if
you asked what the purpose of a doctor
is to heal the sick or what the purpose
of it teacher is to educate people or
what the purpose of lawyer is or what
the purpose of an architect is or what
the purpose of an engineer is.
So,
so why is it that we would come to this
on answer that the purpose of business
is to maximize profits.
When I have known literally hundreds of
entrepreneurs in my life,
and with very few exceptions,
very few of them actually created their
businesses to try to maximize profits.
Of course they need to make money,
but that's,
I need to eat in order to live,
I need to breathe in order to live.
I need my,
I need to create red blood cells in
order to live.
But that's not the purpose of my life to
eat,
to breathe,
to create red blood cells.
Uh,
I haven't much more transcendent purpose
in my life.
That gives my life meaning and value to
it.
Business is no different.
Um,
uh,
business has the potential for a higher
and deeper purpose.
And that's the first principle of
conscious business.
Second principle is,
is that there's a variety of
stakeholders that are interdependent,
that are connected together,
customers,
employees,
suppliers,
investors,
communities,
both local and larger communities.
And then the larger environment that
were part of those are the most
important stake holders.
There are other stakeholders that are in
like an form of wider circle such as,
uh,
the government,
labor unions,
uh,
the media activists of various kinds.
But the idea being that,
um,
these stakeholders are interdependent on
one another and that the conscious
business attempts to create value
simultaneously for all of these
interdependent stakeholders that it
seeks to win,
win,
win business strategy.
That in maybe a way to explain that in a
simple model version is a retail
business,
which whole foods is,
is that,
um,
management's job is to help our,
is to hire good people,
train them well and helped him to be
happy and fulfilled in their workplace,
in their work and their jobs.
And then the team member's job is to
satisfy our customers,
help the customers to be happy in their
exchanges with the business.
So happy team members leads to happy
customers and happy customers,
do more business with the,
uh,
with the company and that leads to happy
investors.
So you have a virtuous circle of happy
team members,
happy customers,
happy investors,
uh,
that reflects in a simplified version,
this idea of the interdependent nature
of the stakeholders and why you can't
just focus on creating value for the
investors alone because you must create
value for the team members who then
create value for the customers who then
create value for the investors.
So,
um,
the conscious business is,
recognizes as conscious of it and works
to optimize value for all of the key
independent,
or dependent stakeholders.
Third principle of the conscious
business is what we call conscious
leadership.
Or you might also think of it as servant
leadership that,
that the leaders of the organization,
they're not there to line their pockets
and try to maximize their own personal
gain.
Instead,
they're job is to fulfill the higher
purpose of the business,
recognize and fulfill the interdependent
stakeholder model and in a sense to
serve the organization to um,
uh,
sublimate their own ego and their own
ambitions for the good of the
organization.
And again,
it's not self sacrificial or I'm not
talking about altruism,
I'm talking about recognizing that in
the long term they will also gain the
most through the flourishing of the
business and through flourishing of all
the stakeholders,
they too will flourish,
that their identity is linked and their
own,
um,
their own gain is linked to the gain of
all these other stakeholders.
And then the fourth principle is,
is that to realize these first three
principles,
you have to create a culture,
a conscious culture that has strategies,
structures,
and processes that create a culture that
optimizes the stakeholder model,
fills the purpose and allows the
conscious leadership to do their jobs.
So the culture provides that background
and the processes and structures that
the conscious business needs in order
to,
uh,
to achieve its highest potential.
So when you add those four principles
together,
you have a conscious business.
When you add the conscious business with
the key principles of the,
of the conscious of the conscious
capitalism,
you truly have the larger ecosystem of
the conscious capitalistic society,
one with conscious businesses that are
changing in a consciously a capitalistic
way.
You've just articulated what I call the
tradeoff myth.
Um,
the belief that all this sounds very
good,
very idealistic,
but it won't compete well in the
marketplace.
And when it runs up against,
say,
a business that's not handicapped with
this,
uh,
idealism,
then it'll be in trouble.
Nothing could be further from the truth.
It's exact opposite that in fact,
the conscious business has competitive
advantage.
When you work from a higher purpose,
you,
you unleash greater degrees of
commitment to greater degrees of loyalty
and greater creativity in the workplace.
And that gives competitive advantage.
When you work from the stakeholder
model,
um,
you understand that you're trying to
optimize the entire system.
You're able to do that in such a way is
when you optimize the entire system,
you also optimize the,
the,
the value that you also,
you're creating for the investors as
well.
The business tends to flourish at a
higher level.
So in fact,
the conscious business will win in most
instances.
All other things being equal,
it will win in competition against less
conscious businesses.
And that's why I'm confident that over
the long term,
conscious capitalism is going to
triumph.
It will,
I believe it will become the New
Paradigm,
uh,
in the 21st century.
Eh,
not because it's,
it's more idealistic or it sounds
better.
It'll become the dominant paradigm
simply because it will win.
It will win in the marketplace and
nothing succeeds in capitalism more than
success itself.
So good ideas that work spread and the
competitive nature of the marketplace is
going to lead to these competitions
between conscious businesses and less
conscious businesses and uh,
uh,
the conscious businesses,
all other things being equal,
we're going to win most of those
battles.
And so fairly quickly,
meaning when I say quickly,
I mean 25,
30,
35 years,
we're going to see more and more and
more conscious businesses and we will
make this shift towards conscious
capitalistic society.
My first instinct is to tell you that I
do think retail is one of the first
areas to shift.
Um,
possibly because they are dealing with
their customers,
uh,
on a day to day basis and they've got
their more labor intensive as well.
They tend to hire and employ more people
like whole foods,
market employees,
57,000
people.
So we're,
um,
and we have millions of customers.
So in a sense,
uh,
and we're in a extremely competitive
marketplace,
food retailing,
and we don't have any patents.
We don't have any in the government's
not protecting a US in some way from
competition.
So,
and we have formidably competitors are
much larger than,
than us.
So like Walmart,
Kroger,
safe way,
companies like that.
So,
uh,
retail,
is one of the first areas to shift.
And many of the conscious businesses
that I know tend to be either retailers
or service businesses,
companies like the container store or
costco or starbucks or the southwest
airlines.
Um,
uh,
the,
these are,
um,
uh,
are businesses that trader Joe's,
these are businesses that our retailers
we're service oriented.
So I do think maybe the conscious,
a conscious business revolution,
conscious capitalism,
Ra revolution,
we'll see that take hold in a more large
scale way in the retail and service.
First.
I can predict also possibly what will be
last.
I predict possibly Wall Street will be
last,
uh,
or the,
pure financial part of our economy,
which to a greater extent it steak,
it doesn't have as much of a stakeholder
model.
It does tend to be dominated by the,
the,
uh,
profit,
profit maximization model and
shareholder return model to a greater
degree than other segments of our
society.
So I suspect retail and services will be
first and the financial sector will be
last.
I do think that,
um,
the economy is going to continue to
evolve towards a more service.
Uh,
the human beings are doing more things
to serve one another in terms of
services.
Uh,
uh,
but the new things or if you think about
the whole technology area,
so much of that didn't even exist 10,
15 years ago.
There was no facebook,
there was no google,
there was no ipods or no i-phones.
Uh,
really blackberries didn't even exist 15
years ago.
So,
so many different things change so
rapidly,
uh,
and new industries and whole industries
can be created fairly,
fairly quickly.
Um,
I think it's safe to say that we're
going to see greater innovations in
education.
That here's an area that needs radical
innovation,
that we don't allow competition,
we don't allow,
we haven't unleashed human creativity.
So education potentially if we could and
monopolize education and truly allow
entrepreneurs to get going on that,
uh,
that can't think of hardly healthcare
and education are the two most regulated
areas in our society.
And they're also the ones that are most
or least satisfactory to people.
Those are areas that we need to to d
monopolize and allow more competition to
occur.
So those are two huge areas,
education,
uh,
and healthcare,
both service areas.
So those are growth industries also
think all types of leisure travel is a,
as a,
as a society becomes more fluent.
It's,
it's desire to travel a increases and to
explore that.
The younger generation today,
people that are in their twenties,
for example,
they have traveled so much more than my
generation had.
I mean for me a big deal when I was in
my twenties and going down Mexico and
that was like the foreign country or
maybe you get up to Canada,
but today people haven't just gone to
Europe.
Uh,
but they've gone all over the world by
the time they're 30 years old.
If they're young and well educated,
they,
they've world travel is going to be
continued to be a,
uh,
it's a goal in particular as
globalization continues to occur,
we're going to continue to explore.
Also think I'm a huge,
huge possibilities and entertainment.
I mean,
look how much entertainment has evolved
and shifted.
Uh,
in a sense,
something like big think it's education,
it's entertainment.
Uh,
it's a,
it's a synthesis of those two and it's
probably got lots of other things in it
as well that I haven't just picked up
yet.
Um,
I do see lots more creativity,
loss,
more innovations,
lots of more entrepreneurship around,
uh,
around entertainment and a human's,
educating one,
another entertaining one,
another serving one another,
uh,
new ways for humans to enjoy life,
new ways for humans to learn and grow.
Uh,
uh,
we are going to continually try to
figure out ways to serve ourselves
better.
And,
uh,
it's,
it's amazing how even think about
something like [inaudible] I didn't
exist in any kind of scale 25 years ago.
Yoga existed,
but hardly anybody did it.
Now you see those are,
or activities that are also leading to
greater human flourishing through
helping humans to be a more fit and
stronger.
Uh,
the more flexible.
So it's fascinating watching the world
and watching humans,
uh,
evolve and watching our society evolve.
It's,
uh,
I love it.
I'm,
I'm so glad to be part of it and to have
contributed a little bit to it myself.